le café de la gare qui a vu démarrer sur
ses planches des gens tels que coluche
miu miu patrick dewaere et romain
bouteille fête ses 30 ans 30 ans de rire
et d'insolence reportage sylvain le kent
jacques gautier le café de la gare à la
il n'y a pas de gars c'est le cas wilaya
et alors on fête l'anniversaire les 30
angle du café de la gare et ses traits
trêve ça me fait un effet bizarre comme
si j'étais sur une paroi avec le vertige
de tomber trente ans d'une belle
histoire pour romain bouteille et un
retour sur les planches de ses débuts
les planches d'un café théâtre pas tout
à fait comme les autres
créé avec une bande de copains qui
avaient pour nom coluche miu miu ou
patrick dewaere tous y ont fait leurs
premiers pas sur scène une bande de
joyeux lurons qui avaient en commun le
même esprit contestataire le même refus
de l'ordre et de l'obéissance i comme eu
ce qu'ils voulaient absolument qu'on
construise inter il était barman chez la
mère au trail dans un café théâtre
c'était là dans la foulée des événements
de 68 voiliers et ont continué on
n'avait pas d'ambition d'être avant
gardiste ambition d'être différent parce
que jusque-là de dan ar qu'ils ne nous
disaient plus rien il fallait trouver un
enfer fabriquer un endroit où le mode
d'expression serait complètement
différent au bout de trois semaines
évidemment adresse a commencé à se
remplir et ans il était habituel de voir
quelqu'un qui prenait la lance à
incendie pour empêcher pour arroser ceux
de la foule derrière pour empêcher
qu'ils écrasent de vendre le climat il
est resté il ya un goût on ne peut pas
décrire un goût
[Musique]